podcast man to see me on there let's go
I can't podcast
I have not been so excited to do an
interview for a very long time
my favorite rapper in the entire world
man don't boost me like that my head
already big as hell man big X the plug
is here
you guys have heard me talking about
this guy for a long time on the podcast
I bring you up all the time whoever's on
the show
so
um it's just man it's good to see you
bro appreciate you man I'm happy to be
here how's the tour
stressful man stressful I'm living out
of cities I'm living out of people
but I just closed on the house back home
congrats
I just want to say we also got Rose Tom
in the building who is an incredible MC
who's on a lot of people listening to
you they've heard him incredible uh the
whole Cruise here you just closed on a
house for some reason
the world is like the algorithm is
pushing me on Instagram to move to Texas
because all I do is get these tick tocks
on my Ig feed that say this is what
three hundred thousand dollars can get
you in Frisco Texas so that's where I
moved to Frisco Texas so you're living
like a god yeah I'm straight right now
and like I show my wife
I just paid 1.3 million dollars for my
house in Burbank
and it's a very modest house
I'll be seeing in Frisco Texas bruh and
I'm like
how far is that from Dallas
I'm doing research I'm like what kind of
flight is that to La I'm like man we
might have to go to jack up
I'm married
we're keeping it either way you know
what I'm saying
strapped up out there yeah for sure go
watch the white greatness of Luke Duncan
in person you know what I'm saying
you got a lot now Texas is man the cost
of living is amazing yeah
yes yeah
um
which city in your opinion I know you
haven't been to L.A much but LA or Texas
on the Mexican food
definitely
yeah that Mexican OT lied to everybody
when it came on into Texas oh no I don't
know why he did that I mean you got your
select few but LA's is different it's
crazy to watch the Renaissance of Texas
hip hop and again like
there's been a lot going on in Texas
over the last decade
um there's been like obviously we can't
be ignorant to the fact Travis Scott's
from Houston making the Steins from
Houston a guy like yellow Beezy had a
huge hit record who's from Dallas both
three wrestling Malone post Malone is
from Dallas the biggest of the biggest
Dallas Texas he's got a Cowboys tattoo
he's from Grand Prairie but definitely
it's Dallas I think his dad worked for
the Cowboys
um but just in terms of like the
camaraderie now and I just feel like
there's just a special energy between
yourself Roe I feel like that Mexican OT
is having a moment the Dallas H-Town
connection is strong now as to where I
feel like we really only thought about
Houston yeah or you know shout out to
UGK you know what I'm saying from Port
Arthur but uh but what do you what do
you attribute to like the current
you know moment that's happening I
really feel like just like me like
people like me Ro like I said make sure
no tea and it's it's a couple of other
artists it's just like a breadth of
fresh air like because like you said for
the for the longest
Dallas and Houston like it's Texas but
everybody was just kind of doing their
own little thing like Dallas had what
they had going on he used to work for
Houston San Antonio was for San Antonio
everybody was just for theyself and I
feel like people like me that Mexican OT
kind of opened it up to
like we just opened you know we just
opened it back up like gave people
made people wanna
do music again if they make sense like
everybody you guys are unapologetically
Texas yeah yeah so you gotta you got to
put on for the state
that's how I found you was uh like
December of last year I was I was uh me
and my kids were
driving a big bear that's doing the most
necessary
and the Texas all came on yeah oh my God
this voice is crazy yeah and then from
there I just was dived it dude I just
died in and I was like appreciate that
man how have I never heard of big extra
blood this is crazy but but you guys are
like again you're unapologetically Texas
I've been thinking about those ot's
record that's on top 100 right now
yeah yeah you got it going crazy right
now well yeah Texas man it's just I
don't know like I feel like Texas than I
always
stuck behind each other but like I said
it's kind of been slipping lately and
it's been isolated yeah yeah that too
and so with me and that Mexican OT kind
of just yelling
Texas you know just putting on for it's
kind of made everybody want to like
reunite or just unite in general so like
that's like when I got my chain I got
sauce walking so I was always one of the
first people called me like yeah man
you're going crazy so I just feel like
we bringing all that back like I did
something with Mike Dom so boom that's I
believe in San Antonio so it's just
we're just bringing Texas back to one I
feel like Texas is going to be the
Atlanta and well my father Memphis right
now because Memphis got it unlocked yeah
and I feel like Texas is gonna we finna
I mean listen everybody loves Texas
already I mean it's a lot of people like
Loki got cribs there
like but this is because of the like
it's the cost of living and then it's
like it's a big Market a lot of people
well a lot of people do know but they
try to keep it but Dallas and just Texas
in general is a huge Market Dallas and
Houston are huge emergencies especially
like if you think it's just media size
oh my God and so that's why a lot of
those people
cost of living solid and then you guys
have amazing uh advancing establishments
yeah yeah we were just talking about oh
yeah
I got the BYOB over there
I never even knew but until I went to
Texas so I just put liquor in a water
bottle for the first it was nice I won
the first time but I had to put liquor
in a water bottle after two o'clock at
the club right here out here yeah oh
yeah what no that's trash but yeah that
welcome to Cali or or the West Coast in
general I mean I own a nightclub in
Scottsdale so yeah there's one's like
155 hits It's liquor pickup
out there too and I believe we couldn't
even control the bottle like they had a
lock on the bottle and uh never ever in
my life had been I think I spent like
500 for a while there is a lock that is
crazy you can't drink out of it
technically you're not supposed to
yeah I can't read that's crazy it's
crazy man it is wild
um yo I gotta ask you one random
question
on safe house when you kept your running
out of breath in and then you re-hitch
your line was that what happened did you
run out of breath and you were like no
keep that in so just let me tell you my
perspective before you answer because
I'm thinking this guy's overweight yeah
I'm like it's one of the most fire
things I've ever seen an artist do yeah
well because you were just going in and
then you almost like kind of got winded
and you might not keep all that in and
then you picked it right back up okay so
boom if you watch the video you can't
hear me breathing them out so the the
audio they got dropped wasn't the the
master mix to master version so like you
could hear all of that
extra stuff in the back like you can
hear me breathing heavy and all of it
but the YouTube version wouldn't but it
just so happened it went crazy they
loved it so oh so but was that what
happened you read like genuinely
romantic breath I ran out of breath but
it was I meant to like it was always
meant for me lions fat guy ever seen an
artist
I appreciate it
biggie didn't do that break it off but
out of breath biggie was a big pun was
running out of breath they didn't keep
that dead I was like it's hard yeah I
mean I started off putting on for the
Big Fellas first
putting out for the Big Fellas my CD
didn't the state I appreciate you for
wearing a shirt I was I was afraid that
if you came here shirtless I was gonna
then
to take my shirt off and see So lately a
lot of people I can't go nowhere without
my shirt now like I walk in place my
manager's like all right come on give it
to me
I love what you're talking about give me
a shirt they don't want you in there
unless you got your shirt off it's like
your trademark yeah so Matt's like well
if that's what they want they got to pay
for it so now I try to go everywhere
with it straight on and they're like
come on man take it off and I'm like
what you want for have you ever heard of
the comedian Bert Kreischer okay so he's
this white dude he's one of the biggest
comedians in the world
but he does all his stand-up he's a
chubby white dude he has to have a shirt
off it's like his thing everyone screams
like he almost can't do comedy with a
shirt on it's kind of he's kind of I
feel bad you made the right choice to be
like I'm gonna start wearing it because
then you're just always going to be the
naked dude yeah yeah exactly I mean it
was crazy I'm the most comfortable naked
I feel like I was a nudist in my I was a
nudist in my past life I don't know
about everybody else but in my past life
I was a naked man for sure for sure for
sure and so now I don't know I just I've
always been comfortable like I was a
football player so I'm always yeah been
comfortable just with my body like if I
wanted to right now I can go to the gym
and I look like got them a black Brock
Lesnar you know what I'm saying
I don't know what that means that's a
signature move oh that's his signature
yeah I know Brock Lesnar as the UFC
fighter I know I watch wrestling I
didn't I didn't see him in the wrestling
here I was a big Randy Orton fan yeah
you know about the RKO yes sir I used to
I used to bang on the floor and drool
out of my mouth yeah and then hop up and
yeah I used to do that got in trouble
for it a lot but I used to do a shirt
off I mean you know Stone Cold the goat
is from Texas I just I didn't like I
don't like beer so I never I never liked
it when he did that he nasty he nasty
what do you drink
I just started drinking liquor now that
I'm like a a rapper I'm out all the time
right so now you're starting to drink
more yeah I drink one step first bottle
gone it's like we five bottles in now
but what are you drinking cause
amigosado yeah that repo is good yeah
that's that's the thing for me it used
to be Hennessy though but we used to
shut down every clip so we had to stop
everyone switched yeah yeah we had a lot
less violent of a drunk if you're off
exactly I'm fighting or I'm naked I'm
I'm naked both
no it's crazy
um I was gonna ask you like a
who would you consider because again
like I hear so much obviously I hear the
Texas in you but when I hear you I'm
like man this motherfucker's rapping
like
he I'm just curious who your influences
are bro who are you listening to as far
as rapping yeah like who's so like
when I was my mom it was like a bunch of
UGK so I UGK Lil Wayne that was it yeah
that was it but when it came to my dad
it was no rap like my pops would listen
to whatever was on the radio but other
Medics Isley Brothers there's a bunch of
slow stuff for him yeah yeah so I feel
like that that's like you can hear that
in my music you know what I'm saying and
so so as far as this influences I ain't
really I didn't want to be a rapper so I
never just was like oh I look up to this
rapper I want to be like that rapper it
wasn't I mean what was what was the
dream before hip-hop was a football I
was a football player yeah you were like
going to try to really were you I could
have went to the league lineman yes sir
by the way I I mean that was an obvious
of course
have you seen this guy he's got a video
I played middle linebacker at first
and then but I was like I was
I was fast but I was too big to play
middle linebacker yeah so they was like
let's put you on the end and I got on
the DNA was okay now you're too small to
play this so
it was they were they they actually made
me eat they made me so what were you
defense attack or offensive lineman I
started off as a middle line but I don't
know you talking about what did you end
up like yeah I ended up for sure for
sure the wall to protect the quarterback
yes sir somebody had to do it what was
your uh like like how far did those
aspirations go did you end up playing in
college yeah I went to college I played
college football for it I went uh for a
semester but I was just homesick I was
bored Minnesota oh like the Badgers so I
was in I was supposed to but I had to go
do uh it was only supposed to be a year
at like this Juco out there yeah and I
was gonna transfer
the first semester Minnesota is an
interesting place because it's like
when we think of Minnesota we think of a
lot of whites you know yeah but
Minneapolis is a Vibe I was in uh uh
like princess from there yeah he is and
that's crazy yeah you got to pass by his
house to go to the Mall of America and
it's just like a big it's like a big
ball yeah with purple lights on it
Incredible God rest your soul rest in
peace so you didn't like Minnesota no no
mosquito whenever it's not cold the
mosquitoes try to kill you and then
whenever it's cold
it's cold so it's never it's cold it's
the worst place to live yeah for sure
because it's [__] freezing
imagine having to play games in there
practicing that
oh I can't even imagine practicing in
the snow or in that cold I never
imagined believing until I was down
there it was Hill yeah in Texas football
is a religion bro yeah High School
football is like I think a Friday Night
Lights and [__] yeah for sure it's like
really like [__] and it brings a lot
of people it feels like in Texas it
probably brings a lot of people together
otherwise wouldn't be together I feel
like that's why I'm I'm able to
like handle the rap stuff how I handle
it because of football like
coach Groves you did an amazing job
because he he he he taught me how to
like really just with life in general
football helped me with a lot you just
gotta you know discipline to make it
even to make it to a junior looking for
the word and he took it right out of my
mouth yeah cause it's a lot of fake
crazy ass stuff they're going in this
industry man and just that just helped
me keep my composure and just stay in my
Lane that's another reason why I feel
like
Adam I've been blessed and been able to
do what I do because I stay in my own
and I don't worry about nobody else if
you got something going on with this
person okay cool you got something going
on with this person okay cool ain't got
nothing to do with me I'm still I do the
song I do a song with the both of you
yeah I'm Switzerland I'm I'm in the
middle yeah I don't know they got
nothing to do with me I'm from money I'm
for I'm for taking care of my child do
you think because I like I said they're
they're obviously has been a like there
was like a little emotion going in
Dallas but there's a lot of division
that was obviously publicized in Dallas
obviously God Rest mode three so he
passed away
um but they're always felt like any time
there was some [__] popping in Dallas
you would just I would just see like
people beefing with each other there's a
lot of negativity coming out um I feel
like that's not the same energy that's
happening right now
in terms of like just on from a Fan's
perspective the way I like it take you
and I'm like oh this dude's just raw
like and that's what I'm saying is
that's why I was like Texas I feel like
is is trying to unite because since I've
been rapping like yeah you got your you
guys are people saying whatever but as
far as like you're gonna have your
haters yeah you're gonna have those but
as far as the like as far as the rappers
who everybody is for it you know what
I'm saying because they see somebody who
got their head down who just
trying to take care of his people yeah
so it kind of make them like
okay well if he doing he ain't doing
that but keeping his head down doing
everybody they like the music but all
the other stuff you ain't got to do that
for what what is that doing yeah other
than taking people's lives and you know
what I'm saying
so I don't know I just feel like it's
showing people that
you can you ain't got to do all that too
how big of an impact just from like a
kid coming up in Texas doing hip-hop was
someone like mo3 on you like because he
obviously I feel like was unfortunately
more appreciated after his passing no
for sure uh I mean if we're being honest
uh he had like he had like songs in the
city that just was obviously viral so
everybody knew him but I didn't really
listen to Three until after he passed
when he passed I listened to his whole
album to this day right so but I'm not
gonna say that
I just was oh I was I was a three fan
yeah no I wasn't until after when he
passed yeah and that's when I just
really started making music anyways
you're like damn like this dude really
was doing a lot of art a lot of the
melodic [__] at a high level he was
definitely something different and if it
wasn't before me it was gonna be him for
sure for sure 100 man I agree uh you're
obviously a Cowboys fan right no no okay
this is interesting who's your team
I want to say I was to take some Spanish
whoa Texas
Jesus Christ you're getting rubbing
tongues with DeShaun Watson or what
what's going on and that's that's the
whole reason when I was a Debian Clowney
first
[__] beast
you meant to say Bust but he was a beast
in college he was and then and then
obviously JJ Watt everyone thought you
had JJ Watt Clowney it's over but it
wasn't over we had uh clown I mean we
had the badger we had the defense was
stacked at one point in time yeah honey
badger was on the team oh so you're a
[__] you're from Dallas and you're a
Texans fan
what is going on there I don't think I
like football no more I don't think I
ever how does that happen it was the
players like I was a I used to be a
Cowboys fan like I used to watch my dad
throw the controller at the TV a lot of
that hadn't left the game did you decide
I don't want to live this stressful life
I did I watched my dad if I damned her
father his knees one game and I said oh
no oh yeah I can never be like that and
so I ended up falling in love with JJ
Watts Davey and clowning people like
that man it just kind of Drew me to
restart off with JJ though and that kind
of Drew me to the team and then
I just was a Texas Fan after that did
your dad look at you like yeah how could
you asked me for it I
can imagine
well I'm a Suns fan and one of my
younger Sons is pretty much growing up
in La so he's a Laker fan and I hate him
for it like [__] if he was in here
probably say he ain't in the damn Texas
but then but when the suns are in the
finals he wants to put on the [__]
son's Jersey that's crazy it's a little
nine-year-old ass yeah I'm pretty sure
if the Texans ever go to the Super Bowl
he don't want to be there
but as and if the Dallas Cowboys ever go
to the Super Bowl
I don't do that don't do that I almost
said without laughing but come on guys
don't do that Mike McCarthy's your coach
anyway oh man I'm sure you'll support uh
yeah I got two man I got two not two you
guys got the crazy I went to
WrestleMania
at your stadium in Plano it's not Plano
I stayed in Plano Madison uh the stadium
is in Arlington no I stayed in Plano by
the way shout out to Plano some chicks
over there they've been playing that too
yeah there's a uh what's the name of
that restaurant where they dress like a
lumberjack prostitutes
uh uh boomerjacks no no no no it's like
Hooters but like like [__] checkered
you got boomerjacks you got Twin Peaks
Twin Peaks
into a twin peaks in Plano and at a time
you gotta go to uh the Twin Peaks what's
the one that we'd be going to before we
go to the club
yeah nice shout out to Plano
no but I went to the [__] stadium for
Wrestlemania that [__] was crazy
so a lot of people don't even know
that's why I don't I damn nearly kind of
got to be a Cowboys fan again because I
just like the technique just did a Remix
They want me to do a remix for Texas for
for the stadium next year just for the
stadium for the Cowboys I mean for the
Cowboys for the stadium oh you're a
Cowboys fan
which one of those overpaid bumps
jerseys are you gonna wear with the
video
ain't even on the team anymore
Dak Prescott like come on like you know
you know who's a beast wear the Dick's
Jersey Diggs
Tavon Diggs is a [__]
yeah yeah
yeah not a fan of him huh
do you guys have some interactions or
something
I mean I am an interactions with nobody
out of all of the Cowboys players since
you've been able old enough to go to
clubs who's the most outside
okay you want to be honest
man who's outside so I like I go to
clubs but I'll go to like I still go to
Hole In The Wall I was like I love
that's my [__] I go to who showed me
love from the jump yeah and so for the
first time ever I went to like a
I go in there
and every Cowboys play isn't it
decking there with it but he [__] up
uh it was just everybody was in there
everybody was in there so I can't even
just say one of them because they was
like you should have brought your dad
with you so he could have went over to
Dak and said get the [__] home and study
so we could win a [__] playoff game
you soft ass [__] what are we
doing I look at him I said that's why
y'all know women
I'm a Sons fan and I have good friends
on the sons
and a couple of them just they're at my
club a lot right so they're big
customers for our club you know 11 11 in
Scottsdale and uh
during the season you know I gotta be
like hey do I say something you gotta
leave an eight hey man are you sure you
wanna
buy 10 bottles tonight there's a game
tomorrow damn
yeah yeah
and they pay it too every time because
they yeah I've never been to a club
where you you literally get ones just to
throw them just it's like a men hanging
party just to stupid see who Miss saying
I I endorse I'm not gonna lie okay it's
a bunch of Cowboy players in there I
gotta I gotta try to do something but I
ended up gaining some friends Jalen was
named Jalen rigger oh yeah our weaker
yeah there you go yeah he's the white
out yeah he was on an eagle he was on
the Eagles yeah he played for uh
Minnesota now yeah probably those for
Minnesota yeah yeah he was there a lot
of people there what about have you ever
hung with DeSean Watson no I have not I
probably will probably I feel like he'd
be a good time
just go hit an Asian massage parlor with
him
at the club and he said hey man I got
this have you ever been to a rub and tug
it's like a massage parlor right where
you go to and there's like a little old
Asian lady in Sherlock rub you down uh I
want to one time and then she'll flip
you over and then she'll jerk you off I
want to but I don't want to know that
that's what it is you kind of gotta know
that's what it is though otherwise it's
awkward no it's not gonna be awkward
I feel like it's not going to be ugly if
you go to one and you don't know it's
like kind of just like a oh it says like
what is this what is this why are you
reaching around and then you just go you
just go with the flow I don't think it's
a just yeah I feel like you knowing that
you're going now now you got to sneak in
and no I just I'm gonna go get a massage
um how does the because obviously we're
in LA and uh you know the politics of
Los Angeles are widely spoken about
um uh you obviously are from a certain
area in Dallas and represent certain
something from Dallas what is the
difference because when we think of like
LA and like Crips and bloods out here
there's a lot of [__] sets that beef
sets and the politics are just once you
dive in like it's if you're not from La
once you come here and you learn
everything you're like whoa yeah what's
it like out there so like honestly
like it's out here
I feel like it's basic step behind this
[__] more for sure but it out in Dallas
it's like you gotta this is not what it
is it's not what it is yeah you know
what I'm saying like yeah you got a
bunch of people that claim this claim it
but I feel like I said more people fight
for their hoods then they they six like
I got a one of my partners is
what I'm saying but allegedly
yeah allegedly so but yeah
yeah I don't know it's just it's
different yeah it's different that's
good because like out here like you know
you can't you couldn't wear [__]
Houston Astros hat out here I told that
I was like hey bro I tell everybody
don't wear Yankees don't wear Astros I
mean really you can't wear many hats if
you're not gonna be
like if you're gonna be in the valley or
like your show or something Mercy is
different if you like go hang out to go
eat like in la la you got to kind of
watch your uh fitted Choice let's see I
mean it's different when you can you can
you can vouch behind your seat you know
what I'm saying so
somebody might try to check you you just
got to be you got to say do you have
like big homies in L.A I make some type
of people as we speak I don't know what
I'm saying but that's the right thing to
do yeah I mean but it's like it's
different when a [__] say oh you got a
chicken and because that sounds a little
like yeah like no I'm not checking in
nowhere but you know if you hear me like
hey man I [__] with what you got going
with me listening it's different it's
about the approach it's different and so
we had a couple people do that so when
you're in the process that's happening
with those people right now uh any LA
Hip Hop you're listening to or anybody
who you [__] with out here uh [__]
Greedo just did his house arrest time
prison sentence out there and I need to
you did and I [__] agreed up and I
need to talk apologize to him right now
on your podcast because he sent me a
song that he wanted me to do I think he
wanted me to be on his next project and
I ended up getting my whole new phone so
I lost remember even I still had his
Instagram but it was just like I kind of
had forgot that he even it happens but
when you just said it I was like Credo
damn you smile here damn we were
supposed to do a song together
so yeah I apologize to you my boy and if
you still want me to do that song matter
of fact on the team when we leave here
we got to stop the interview real quick
and tell you about our folks at my
bookie man look my bookie NFL season is
approaching and you know what they just
added that I love is that early cash out
let's say you got a ticket and it's
looking great you can cash out early on
that ticket all right I love it all
right plus of course my book he's got
the full casino going down and if you
sign up right now using the promo code
bootleg they will give you that first
deposit bonus up to a thousand dollars
all right so head over to my bookie ASAP
um look we're at uh NFL coming there's
baseball you can gamble on right now and
of course the full service casino
blackjack with the real dealer uh
roulette craps whatever you're into slot
machines you could do it and cash out
right on my bookie all right all you got
to do is sign up with that new promo
code bootleg when you sign up
trust me when I say it's a new account
they're gonna get you that uh first
deposit bonus all right so go to uh my
bookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpong
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
cab podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg kingpom.com and uh man trust me
the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpong.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
um you obviously dropped the deluxe to
your album which in my opinion is one of
the best projects of the year
um what how I mean obviously you're on
the road right now but you also just
were in Arizona working on new music
yeah
um so what is the are we getting some
new [__] soon obviously yeah you just
put a single out uh with uh yeah yeah
that one going crazy but you know we're
on tour right now so we already we just
scheduled out to mix Four single drops
uh hard man you know after that we come
with like an EP or something I'm not I'm
not changing nothing why don't y'all do
it like a joint album oh that's on the
way
that's gonna be the I'd like I just
started the label 600 entertainment yeah
so that's gone I'm gonna need a chain
two for sure all my people got them I
was like so I got you how did you guys
link up we actually made it senior year
high school so I got kicked out of three
schools my senior year oh wow he was one
of them I was I was a football player
but I had got big hit it like I had
offers everywhere yeah like that's where
I ended up having to go to a Juco
because
my head got so big you were getting in
trouble I got kicked I swung on the
coach and uh my first school oh [__] I
kicked out ended up going to like this
little school in the country play like
four Games took them to the playoffs
right after the football season they
turned out to be very much racist
and yeah so I ended up getting kicked
out of that school the school was racist
yeah in Texas no way
I'm kidding yeah see you're like I'm
talking about like drove around with
Confederate flags on the back of their
trucks so I lived in Florida for a few
years and I didn't even know like I'm
from Arizona which is like there's a
certain element of white trash out there
but it ain't like it's like tweaker like
biker gang white trash it ain't like
redneck white trash right yeah so when I
moved to Florida
when I moved to Florida like um
I I there was a whole new white trash
introduced into my life and it was like
Southern or white trash and these guys
who got like the South will rise again
flags
and I was just like these people are
still oh yeah yeah it was bad they they
I got kicked out of the school for my
safety if that is really what the [__]
yeah what's the name of uh
I left so I when I lived in Florida I
drove
from Phoenix to Tampa Tampa to Phoenix
and I was with my boys who were Brown
and my homie from Houston was like
East Texas there's a town he said
whatever you do don't stop there I think
it starts with a v
but I heard that like in Texas there's
some cities that are like [__] yeah
they're just openly
Ellis County uh uh
you said what you said Tyler Tyler said
yeah that's yeah they they out there
still trying to hang folks oh my God
yeah like it's going down out there the
KKK is very active in Texas I've heard
but another [__] we having meats and
[__] for that yeah it's so crazy because
Texas is one of the let's it reminds me
of Florida in terms of like
you could be like one town over from
like some real lit racist like [__] but
then you go to the next town and it's
like and the white people is that the
black people barbecues that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah cause like man like
when you go to Houston you're like oh
this is a Melting Pot everyone kind of
gets a long like you know yeah you went
to Dallas once I told you I went to
Dallas WrestleMania had a good time but
it was it wasn't my favorite city but I
feel like I did I went I went with the
wrong people gotta go with me yeah yeah
I definitely was like with you know guys
where I was just like
I was like these places are trash
gotta go with me and then we try to get
into a spot was there a strip club
called onyx
back in the day
yeah
um yeah they like blue cheese but it was
like maybe eight years ago right yeah
yeah that was before I was going to
strip clubs maybe it was called Onyx
maybe it was called Babylon because I
don't know but anyway I [__] trying
to go yeah probably was on it for sure I
was just disappointed with the talent
because you had to go to like uh
really just depend on what you like but
Latin and women of colors ecstasy
non-whites yeah yeah I see him I see him
going crazy ecstasy I see we taking the
cab North
ease them into it
by like the third bottle he's having a
great time yeah hey tour is over I'm
coming to Texas for sure
um also you guys are able to carry guns
yes which is a plus in my opinion yeah
but it's they they pull a lot of little
[__] though so like you can you can
have a gun but if you got like they
pulled me over right now I got this with
me because you got the gun it's a
problem it's now unlawful care what yes
oh that's crazy you can't you can't be
doing any you can't run a red light
while you got a gun unlawful unlocked so
if you're breaking any other law while
you have a gun it's unlawful
I forget you guys can't smoke weed
legally there oh we were just we just
had a show in San Antonio and everybody
in my car went to jail but me
for weed my the driver went to jail
because he had he had a gun on him and
he ran a red light boom took him to jail
uh the passenger my little brother
he was a real one you know he yeah he
did what he's supposed to do he went to
jail
um there was another young lady in the
car she had like a little weavement up
in the bottom of her purse went to jail
we're so spoiled here because I don't
even think that I forget that that's
still a thing like people go to jail we
take advantage when we go to States like
this we take advantage like we was just
in New York
just blowing it down right in front of
the police officers they don't give a
[__] they don't give them bro you saw in
New York like you guys walk by the
little tables or people were just
selling weed in the middle of like
everywhere no there's one of these fold
up tables at the park
got ten dollar grams blessings blessings
blessings I don't know if I want that no
yeah what kind of [__] trash is in
those bags yeah for sure oh my goodness
yeah no uh for you man you obviously
done so much independently
um you're headlining your own tour yes
sir you're
doing these numbers that a lot of these
guys on these major labels with these
major coastlines aren't necessarily
doing
what is your game plan moving forward
are you somebody who's gonna obviously
you're always gonna look at all options
but like do you have the aspiration to
continue to be independent do you want
to try to partner for like I definitely
feel like I want to stay independent
just off the strength of
I need my child to be good for forever
like when I if I was to go today my son
for sure good until he 18. yeah and
that's what that's what I care about you
know what I'm saying I don't care about
the man I'm thinking about a longevity
I'm thinking about smart you know what
I'm saying and so I just feel like and
that's the independence the way and then
it's like I still get to I can control I
can control I I can I've never really
had a job because I can't do a manager I
mean like not a manager but like a a
boss figure I can't because I'm a boss
so it's like hey gonna tell me what to
do yeah you know what I'm saying so it
just don't go so now it's like I'm My
Own Boss I got a great team you know
what I'm saying that and we all want the
same thing we all want a longevity of
winning like no we know we're not trying
to just win right now we're trying to
win forever like whenever everything is
all gone we still winning you know what
I'm saying 100 and so I just feel like
now I I ain't gonna say I've done enough
for myself I'm still getting myself to
you know getting up there but now it's
like okay I'm at a I'm at a part in life
where
I'm trying to be done with my option at
um
now I can I want a label deal but it's
like I've done so much I already they
can't come at me with no [__]
[__] because you also know that you
know I mean you're more educated about
the business exactly
I do and I had I had a manager before
I waited for all this and we fell out
and I don't even really [__] with them
no more like that now but
if I was to ever see him before I
reacted I would tell them I just want to
let you know I thank you for telling me
to go to United Masters first because I
could assign a major at first but it was
just I don't like doing stuff that I
don't I understand I don't know the I
don't know yeah because you're gonna
have a [__] 20 Page contract 25-page
contract and then you're paying an
entertainment lawyer who really just
wants to get paid I mean I still had to
do that no no for sure you need a lawyer
right but I mean that's the one thing
I'll say is like a lot of artists like I
see it like you know their team is just
pushing for for whatever the biggest
advances for the male because the now
they get paid on the now they're around
for the now so your manager I'm not
saying that happened to you but like
I've seen this with artists where their
managers are pushing them to sign shitty
deals because they're going to get paid
now off of it yeah and they got five
other clients so they don't really give
a [__] to be around in nine years five
years six years to get the the smaller
bread over time so you artists got to
look out for that man that's awesome I
definitely think I don't know some
managers have you [__] up yeah
um I was gonna say uh for you like what
you know we talked about post Malone
earlier these guys like as someone like
poster like Travis or any of these guys
tapped in nope post Malone
I reached out to Megan
nothing for Megan it's actually going
through a lot you know so overstood
really the biggest biggest thing I've
ever used that to me is Erykah Badu fire
other Dallas Legend
definitely if I always forget she's from
Dallas yeah
[Music]
Erykah Badu
um bumby
is that a trail Burger yet no I was
supposed to have one that rolling out
and I missed that on it because I was
like see I feel like you got to go to
the restaurant now yeah I'm gonna go to
Houston I got a show in Houston so we're
definitely gonna stop by there what's
your biggest Market outside of the State
of Texas because you're doing numbers so
like you gotta have fans everywhere uh
you can look on your back end
oh my what your your back here's
probably your Spotify artist right uh I
just got into the United Method there
please show me
um
I've been having the worst Cinema lately
it's not even low but I'm probably gonna
say like uh so outside of Texas
what about on the tour like what's been
the crazy show
we'll sort out the fastest
I mean it takes mile to Texas things
already sold out but I mean everywhere
every show we indeed then show that yeah
like by the time we get there it's only
like 15 tickets left so that's fire the
walk-in is going to take that they're
gonna take it out yeah
hey Luca or Dirk Dirk oh yeah he got you
the ring yeah come on come on you can't
go can't go against the grain yeah it
can't go against the ground how do you
feel about uh Luca though I mean I feel
like he got dark potential he does feel
like he could be
he seems like not the easiest guy to
play with though I mean it's crazy
because it's somebody that got to be
from overseas to take us there can't be
no hey man that's that but that's Texas
teams in general yeah yeah Ming in
Houston y'all have [__] Tim Duncans
from the Virgin Islands got it Manu
Ginobili
Lucas and Dirk at least you know we love
everybody y'all love everybody I mean
some of y'all love everybody
and then y'all got Kyrie yeah yeah that
was a shot there's not a lot of Defense
getting played
158 to 152 games all year next year
it's cool we're gonna put something
together man I'm gonna talk to him I got
I got livers now I can come up there and
talk to him uh how how much uh are you
you say you got one more album left on
the deal how how close are you to
completing the project
I mean if you're asking me I'm done it's
done features and everything
you know I'm not really a big feature
person I've noticed which is great the
with the album obviously rose on the
album I'm sure yeah but that's that's
different that's like
that man extension of me you know what
I'm saying so like if I I'm I'm the type
of person that would do an album and put
one of his songs on there just just you
know what I'm saying like that so I
don't even become but like with the with
that my thing what I put Eric Banks on
their tape money sauce Walka that was
just
Texas you know I was trying to lock in
Texas so like now
you remember asking me like my NR is
there asking man come on we got to do
some big features who you think we
should do it took me like a month to
finally just be like
to sit down and actually listen to
certain songs and be like okay who could
fit on this yeah and so
I don't I don't like the
because now that I know the business and
I look at numbers and all of that
some of these artists like they will
reach out and they'll be like oh this
amount of money and I'd be like
bro what you're not streaming right now
what are we doing but I know it's part
of the game so well a lot of these guys
unfortunately they're in positions where
that's part a lot of their income comes
from is features and back-end because
they are not in the most
I understand so you know but you don't
get offended when that happens though
because some people get pissed off and
then they figure it out because I know I
know what I would yeah you know so I
understand but
the people that they charge the Army
those people I was just talking about
yeah we not even gonna do them but
people that I am going to do features
with uh I'm gonna do something with uh
I'm trying to get something with offset
fire I got a song on him
um who are you saying Fitness finesse
two times I got a song with him
like you said bro yeah uh
who else he's running around like
everywhere with that little kid rapper I
forget the kids he just followed me on
Instagram and I got so excited last
night I sat with him at the BT Awards
and I thought it was his son because
like finesse two times sits with the kid
and I was like hey what's up man I was
like is this your kid you know um and
he's like no he's a rapper I was like
what I hate him to Freestyle I asked him
to rap and he said I don't rap for free
so I gave him I had Mexican pesos in my
wallet so I was like here's some pesos
and he wrapped and this little kid was
talking like he was a 39 Year Old
Trapper who just got out of prison
I was like what's happening here
it was the craziest [__] ever and I was
like this sounds like the type of kid
that might be raised by finesse two
times
indeed not his son yeah man that's crazy
I thought that was his kid not his kid
just a kid can you just follow me on uh
King yes he was following me on
Instagram last night and I blurted him
out in the Sprint I see y'all Kings just
follow me on Instagram so you finesse
anybody else
uh right now in Maryland too I just came
to hey you're on uh that Mexican Ortiz
album you gotta get down on your [__]
you know we made that song
two years ago really
it was right when we both
started bubbling he reached out to me
and we just at first he was just kind of
vibrant and then he sent me something we
did it he came we shot a video for it
like this one he was on his first tour
oh wow yeah so well you guys uh are both
in my opinion like two of the best
rappers just out here right now also
both of you have an affinity for being
naked
you know
I think you guys should do we've never
been Shameless together not yet
I might keep my shirt on there
I was gonna say
if you guys I mean both of you guys are
independent-ish I know he's with uh
Johnny and good talk and got Upstream
together shut up Johnny shot this feels
like a perfect moment
for y'all to do like
a [__]
collab project together little eight
piece little seven pieces we definitely
we definitely and neither of you should
have shirts on in the cover
foreign
man I mean I feel like that would be
like
[__] this equivalent to like Nas and
Jay-Z coming together and like 98 and
doing an album together listen I gotta
stretch him out because like I said I
got the one coming with row I got one
coming with yay bro no no Shanty Gable
who's incredible as well he's from
Alabama right yeah I gotta tap him man
yes
you and OT yeah we gotta do that too man
that'll be historical yeah
like crazy what was your last real job
my last real job was
I want to say
UPS you where UPS or the ups were you
delivering or were you um
do you have to wear brown
no that's a perk yeah you know that's
for the drivers only I always wonder
because I may or may not know somebody
very close to my life that may or may
not be me that have sent a lot of
marijuana through the mail over 10 years
ago of course
statute of limitations
I always wonder
do the UPS drivers or the UPS Factory
workers if the Box busts open or y'all
think there's some [__] packs in
there
they can definitely just brush that
[__] open if they want to but
have you ever like I always wonder if
they keep it
so it depends like if I'm working at UPS
and a [__] a 10 piece comes through
and it busts open I'm just like how do
we get this out of here so like you said
if
there was somebody like me that worked
at UPS they unloaded the trucks and just
happened to be cool with the person who
you know used to pull up with the trucks
yeah you know in most certain packages
came through you just leave them on the
truck I'm pretty sure that's what they
would do yeah and then hey just just so
you know this one's not going to get
reported missing
like who's gonna call UPS and be like
hey uh so my uh 10 pounds of marijuana
didn't land in Ohio exactly so but a lot
I don't know nowadays they now you can
always tell but man it's like okay do I
just do I bless it open to see what it
is and then if they see it I keep it in
the truck or do uh because there's also
the risk that you also could be just
hating on someone's hustle because
exactly you don't want to [__] on a guy
who's you know sending weed to the man
but it's like technically I don't really
I mean ain't got nothing to do with me
no you know what I'm saying if I if I
find it if you find it it's you just
miss me no it's you for sure but I mean
like if you ain't got the plug with the
guy in the truck
then you're just opening it up it's a
lot harder then look because now you
gotta you gotta try to you gotta take it
out the box you got to try to get it to
the restroom you got to try to put it in
the roof you got a working shift do they
poke the box to see if because I've
heard at the post office they just open
it you can just cut it open and just
retape it wow yeah yeah
it go down in the building
yes have you ever found any uh packs
while I work yeah
allegedly yeah nice but I haven't been
with it because I found it with the
supervisor
yeah so he was like we have to report
this it just smelled like like coffee
beans real bad I know the real so I'm
like
but I know I bust the box over when I
busted up allegedly when I push the Box
open
the supervisor came in I just made it
look like oh what do we have here what
is this what is this and they caught it
in they took them out the truck I was
unloading another truck watching crying
like but damn I could have been me look
that's terrible yeah you gotta you gotta
get creative with how you send stuff in
the mail because of people like you but
it's like in the warehouse it's like
you're coming to him after a while you
know like you got a triple vacuum seal
yeah you know
you can tell when people send them down
like if it's a certain like if it's
something that's worth over I think it
was like fifty thousand dollars they
would put like a white and red bag
around it so that when they won't like
you don't even unload it usually it's
insured right like if someone standing
down
they don't even like you don't even get
to unload it somebody is people that
drive around the warehouse that come and
get the e-rigs from out of the yeah
social probably be a little harder to
bust open exactly yeah nah
did you work there as well you worked at
FedEx
he was a delivery guy emphasis on oh
that's why you got the FedEx video he
got fired for that video actually
wait a minute so you work at UBS you
worked at FedEx
this is like the Bloods and the Crips
coming together right here
uh so you were how long were you a
delivery driver uh what like nine months
in that nine months how much drugs did
you steal from hard-working drug dealers
no comment allegedly allegedly oh
allegedly if there was somebody who was
doing the same job as you how much would
they have taken oh like not you of
course oh probably over
cool little 20 ball Jesus
I know there's [__] like you
because I'd be like yo my shoes
you're looking at the [__] tracking
and then it says out for delivery and it
just is never gets delivered and you're
like oh or it'll say it's there
but yeah but it's not there
or it'll be there it's just be an empty
box and then you just press insured and
you know I mean that to you again wow
yeah bro you're a [__] you know a
crazy guy you're not crazy yeah I know
people man
they think about it we really took over
the warehouse industry yeah
yeah
you know I'm saying I don't seen people
make over
000 in a day
delivery when when the ps5s was was
hiding reading PS files you gotta think
about it PS5 drop when the iPhones drop
okay so I was easy so yeah you're gonna
tell you a funny story allegedly yeah
allegedly of course someone you know
someone you know someone I know right uh
this is right when I'm no longer working
I didn't sign my first little
distribution deal with United Masters
they gave me a nice little bag we rap
I'm rapping now
you working at FedEx allegedly
we're gonna do a show
we gotta do a show
we get pulled over leaving the show
we can put I believe in the show
we got two it's two girls in the car
yeah mine's registered this is mine yeah
he is allegedly what's up from one of
the back of the [__] Finance trucks
you feel me so this is like my first
ever unlawful Carrie this is when I
found out
you can't be doing something illegal why
you got a gun because as soon as they
pull us up I'm like yeah officer I gotta
I got a little bit of weed
I got a gun that's right just to meet up
so you can't really do nothing about it
he's like okay I'm liking me I'm like
yes two guns in the car they both and
somebody's name at the time I'm not even
knowing that this is a legendary so I'm
like it's too good they ain't they both
in the name we good
they put me over they take me to jail
because I had a little bit of weed and
off of carry and they let this [__] go
they ain't even running the guns because
I was so honest with them you know yeah
yeah I got weed and all that so
he made it that day he made it
so it was a missing someone's someone's
gone fell off the back of a truck
allegedly yeah wow so when they say
Things fall off of the back of trucks
they do yeah sometimes
damn hey what kind of swamp ass do you
got driving around as a delivery guy in
Texas that's gotta be [__] just
levels of perspiration that are ungodly
you
know
I don't know
well you guys had doors on at FedEx at
UPS there's like no doors right or do
you guys not have doors
um I wasn't driving them I was driving
in Springfield oh you're in there no no
no I was driving uh the ones without
cameras and [__] you know so you had a
racket going allegedly yeah yeah he was
plugged in hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our folks at
Odd Socks baby shout out to Odd Socks
man the most comfortable socks in the
world Listen they got all the licenses
if you love chips you know what I'm
saying they got the Funyuns they got the
goddamn Doritos
uh they got Godfather was double by Odd
Socks is not only is it the most
comfortable sock in the world that you
could put on your feet but they also
just introduce their draws that's right
we got Odd Socks Basics underwear right
here which are amazing so if you um
if you just like that clean cut you know
we got the black ones or
if you're a fan of
a little bit of the uh Reese's you know
what I'm saying
look go to oddsocksofficial.com right
now use that promo code bootleg and
you'll save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
the basics these are a pair of the
basics these are ah they're just so
comfortable dude like trust me when I
say all right if you're into wrestling
if you're into Transformers Power
Rangers goddamn Pepsi Coke they got both
you know what I'm saying shout out to
Odd Socks oddsoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout also got a shout out to the
family at Blue chew that's right it's
hot as hell outside what does that have
to do with Bluetooth I haven't decided
yet but I do know if you're uh dealing
with erectile dysfunction or maybe your
thing ain't thanging like it should be
thanging you know what I'm saying get
that Bluetooth same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis yes all right but it's
getting straight to your door in a very
discreet package no doctor's
appointments no doctor's visits all
right it's all online bluetooth.com all
right and this was dope about Bluetooth
uh one uh it makes your dick work like
it's never worked before we're just
being honest imagine like Barry Bonds 71
home run season but the dick form that's
how you're gonna be feeling when you're
on these blue shoes all right trust me
when I say it's a chewable form they
just drop their mint chewables as well
um there's so much to go down with
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and they'll send you your first
month for free yes you asking me does
Bluetooth work of course it does find
out for yourself for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg all right go get you
a month of Bluetooth for free
and thank me later your wife will be
thinking me your girl will be thinking
me your dick will be thinking me you
know what I mean all right let's get
back to the interview so you were
working at FedEx I haven't seen the
video so you have a music video
working for FedEx
and they saw it and they pulled the plug
on the kick
nine months in yeah could you you can't
uh record yourself he literally was in
the building getting his packages for
his route
had the cameraman in the van while he
was doing his rap pulled up to people's
houses
oh [__] I'm gonna say hi [__]
I'm already up already a legend yeah
did you try to apply over at UPS
yeah I got hired I just didn't go
it was already serious yo how many times
in life I've been hired and just didn't
go it's been a few like early on in life
when I was like 17 or 18 they'd be like
yeah you're hired and I'm like I don't
want to work at McDonald's oh God I got
hired at McDonald's
my first job
I was 17 I think yeah no I was 16. I was
16 first job at Taco Cabana I got paid
7.75. oh and I think the original pay
was 7.25 so when he told me 775 he
really said it's 7 24 he was mixing he
said it's 7 25 but for you 775 and I was
like I'm in I was like yes yeah yes yeah
what would you buy with your paychecks
back then at 17.
you never played fortnite
this is foreign
Apex Legends though I heard is uh all
right this guy plays it
that's his game so yeah I was kind of
like you know so what about like
non-online games like when you were you
beat like Grand Theft Auto are you
playing like metal or soccer I mean but
like I actually got bored like I play it
I mean FTB missions this [__] is this
boy are you a big gamer bro what are you
outside of fortnite what do you play
Madden 2K yeah I mean at the GTA get
boring it's like no no it's supposed to
be dropping a new one yeah I think I'm
gonna start doing it because I think now
like like man I just got my house yeah
now that you got that giant castle that
I know that is a [__] massive
it's all right it's all right it's built
for a big fella it's got to be so
is that where does Shaq live in Texas
yeah oh he actually got to have some
Dallas I heard Shaq's got a [__]
crib out there yeah he'd be out there so
because he he was from Texas right I
don't think he's from Texas yeah he's
from he's from Texas
straight from Texas he went to school at
LSU but I know he like his dad was in
the military he stepped down oh yeah he
is from Texas yeah a lot of people hey
there's some Texas goats out here
I didn't know that
I think my uncle got b-bombed in
Clarksville wait what happened my uncle
he played basketball with him against
him and he lost in the playoffs damn or
was that the championship one of them
you guys even watch baseball like the
Rangers are they even a thing in your
life you know I've never been to a
baseball like ever game until I just
went into the first pitch at the Rangers
game how was it I didn't see it was it
like a a respectable pitch or did you
hit the dirt oh yeah I threw like the it
was like a 30 mile per hour curve ball
but it wasn't like remember the 50 Cent
pitch was rough yeah
you did what you're supposed to do I
just didn't understand what the [__] was
going on baseball's a terrible sport
yeah I don't go Rangers go Rangers I
mean they played Texas I just watch
football and basketball I like the like
the like the hockey [__] again like I'm
sure do you guys like the Dallas Stars
no but they play Texas so go Stars
I was gonna say you didn't you said play
Texas you didn't say Dallas I was gonna
say you're a [__] traitor because
you're a [__] Texas
no they play Texas they play the song so
oh they play your song Mom Texas is
going crazy right there has there's no
way you walk into an arena in the state
of Texas and they're not playing that
song so that's why everything we saying
go to bed when I heard that song in my
head I just pictured The Source magazine
Don't Mess with Texas cover for Mike my
childhood that's all just playing out in
person you remember that cover uh you
said from your childhood I'm only 25. it
was like J Prince Bun B Mike Jones and
everybody was on this cover and like
pulled out and it was like during that
like real I guess the last time like
places was was lit man so like you don't
know it was a tongue were you listening
to like uh the thing about Dallas people
don't understand is like a lot of like
older Dallas [__] like I think a Doro
you know I think are like some of the
more fun [__] uh yeah my Dougie that's
definitely what Dallas is based off of
right it's more like
get a lot of dancing and [__] and then
when we think of Houston we think of the
screwing shops and all that [__] exactly
um I feel like for you like did you grow
up listening to any of that like more
the the dance dancing I used to be a
dancer [__] everybody was if you
say you wasn't dancing you were from
Dallas you're lying so you could do the
line you got some moves you got some
tick tocks in you you'll see it you got
to come to one of these shows when's the
LA show uh well Friday I'll be there
Friday Friday night I'm [__] coming
pause
hey yo
I've been I've been getting away with
some egregious ones lately man I'm sorry
you're performing yeah uh when is listen
you're about to Freestyle
so you guys are gonna see how crazy he
is as artists but what do you got going
on bro
uh just a bunch of singles right now
yeah just dropping a whole bunch of
things you guys are like [__] you
guys really got came into [__] together
high school together you guys [__]
ran up the shipping War
did you learn a lot from him yeah for
sure that's why I keep him with me
because it's like I still it's still
[__] that I don't know like when it
comes to writing and smoking he's just I
just got the voice then there my voice
is special I got a divorce him no you
could rap bro yeah I mean I just got
something to talk me it's not hard to
well you got something yeah really bad
rappers yeah yeah I just like I saw a
Playboy Guardian concert at rolling loud
and I just was really lost I was like uh
I just a little bit confused
and I I respect his team and I respect
him and I respect their movement but
he's the one artist
because I get most of this [__] it might
not be for me but like you know I'd get
a little Uzi like I'm like yeah this
shit's hard I get it look
playway card is one guy
and I don't know what the [__] going
on imma name one more Jaleel
will he just be doing backflips
I ain't heard one of his songs I just
know that [__] is ripped bro
yeah man I know Jaleel I should check
his music out because I don't want to
speak about his music without having to
listen to it
I just know he is he's got a career in
like you know wrestling wrestling oh my
God he could be a wrestler he already
got a Jaleel yeah yeah no standard
backflips and just he's just [__]
like and I'm like bruh he actually do
like wrestling stunts on his shows I saw
you know I've seen a lot of artists
starting to like do these fake [__]
wrestling moves on fans which is crazy
because if they are real fans it's
dangerous as [__] but there's no way
they're real fans yeah [__] are
doing RKOs in the tables in the middle
of their show and they're like it was a
fan I'm like no it wasn't you're not
just RKO in a random stranger into a
table hell no that's a [__] lawsuit
yeah for sure have you ever this is a
wild question it should have an obvious
no to it but have you ever crowd surfed
nope one of these days I'm gonna get my
big ass up there they don't carry you
bro they better but what you don't do is
I gotta wait till I'm like Beyonce or
Drake levels
I'm gonna get on my knees and just lay
so what you do is pause
you get into the crowd and you find the
biggest [__]
right and then you just tap their
shoulder and you say
and then they'll get you up and then you
start tapping the people in front so
then they'll tap and then this is that
Rock shows for the most part or like a
Tech Nine concert
and then and then they'll then usually
everyone's in communication now what's
dangerous is when you just like out of
nowhere then you jump and your fans
aren't expecting you to do that one you
might die and two you might kill someone
and I mean that with all due respect Mom
I'm an athlete man I feel like I can I
can't you know what I'm saying like in
the middle of the year I can oh [__]
they're not good they're not attention
have you concert yet no no you should do
it both y'all should do it that's why I
keep them with me because the [__] I
can't do yeah he can do like whenever we
in certain stages where I can't get down
bro go
is lit
just don't have money still trying to
[__] rob you you gotta you gotta wait
till we you gotta wait till we like like
super make a story no for sure I feel
like raw wave could crowd surf right now
someone would die though
not if everybody's on the same page
everyone has to be on the same page you
got to say hey hey but yeah
that's why I said it's more of a you
gotta like sit down and just lay back
and just live yes you gotta do this
you're gonna do a slow yeah because if
he jump they're gonna do like but to get
him back on stage
I don't know if you saw Broadway's
broken whole stage before I don't know
if you saw that and I'm gonna take up
for him because that's actually my
favorite artist
that wasn't his fault that was all those
people that were on stage with him also
shot to Rod wave one of my favorite
artists he's from St Petersburg Florida
which I used to live He's a sweet guy
too man yeah I like you know what I like
about Rod wave he's so anti-industry
yeah like he don't give a [__] about
being your friend he ain't trying to
kick it with rappers he's doing none of
the weirdo [__] he's just making records
I'm trying to kick you with your ride
listen listen bro I [__] with you I
don't even got to do no songs but I just
[__] with you and yeah we need to tell
you no I love Rod he and he's like he
can make country he can make pop music I
mean he's just such an amazing
songwriter that'll happen for you man I
mean it's gonna happen uh we was just at
uh G5 of Miami great place he was there
great chicken wings and the wild it was
they said he was there I didn't see him
that happened DJ said old Broadway or
something something what if the DJ
accidentally thought you were Rod wave
that would be [__] up because I get
that all the time I get this [__] out
like you walked in and the guys are like
yo Sean's a rod wave in the building and
you you're like what if that's what the
[__] he was talking about and then
you're like Dion song you're like yo
that's dope Rod waves here but always
playing fight the feeling I am excited
though because I'm singing I'm a singing
word for word
probably so glad your fans say this [__]
out of town like before they are you are
you out
no Okay you're from Texas
and it's like that every time are your
girls permanent are you popular
permanent so I had one of my first no
takeout smart man my first Grill was it
was a pull out but a dog like the smile
a Yorkie like literally chewed the tip I
had diamonds missing and some more [__]
and I was like never again I had a when
I went through my girlfriends it was
because I live in Florida everybody in
Florida got grills grills so the Jeweler
just just gave me some grills
and uh man I just I couldn't get used to
them bruh and then and then you know
what I realized because I would talk to
dudes with grills right
and I'll be like yo why everybody I know
into in Florida
and also could say a lot about the type
of guys I was in close proximity with
talking to just have like really bad
breath
and I was like
is my breath funky because I got metal
in my mouth I don't know
I just stopped wearing them so
it's really like you're supposed to go
get your [__] clean you are you supposed
to go get them took out and clean every
I think it's like every three
not a nice night it's not on someone
it's like every three months you're
supposed to go back to the dentist you
take them off take your actual teeth off
so like they it's like they're cemented
on my on your actual yeah they shaved
your teeth down underneath yeah yeah but
they didn't just they didn't Kodak my
[__] no I know I understand but what
you're saying is every three months
they're supposed to take the Caps off
they scrape they get the semen off clean
my teeth yeah and then I take the actual
diamonds and shoot to Johnny they clean
them that's a Johnny Dang girl wow I'll
go back to to the dentist he put them
back on that's why it's Chris a [__]
commitment yeah how long before you say
[__] this [__] and you get veneers I'm
ready for veneers I was gonna say six
months this is my guess I'm already
really yo I feel like everybody who has
the grills at least besides Birdman who
I think recently took them out because
Birdman was committed shout out to him
but all the homies I know who are
younger they get the grills the perms
and I see them like two months later two
years later and they just they got them
pearly whites
it's always because right it's only
because I just never thought that I
would lose a like a diamond would come
out of
my my mouth and the diamond came out of
my mouth what were you eating or what
happened I wasn't even eating them or oh
I don't know I just I didn't even
noticed it was missing I was in [__]
Arizona recording so I didn't even know
I just I never knew until somebody
pointed to that that damn Diamond's
missing and then you gotta you got
special toothpaste uh you can I mean you
could just it's certain two places that
you can use like I use any toothpaste
right but it's like this black one that
you can use that is supposed to the
charcoal yeah but I don't think it made
no difference and you you just pop yours
out in there back to it I'd be seeing
him do this [__] sometimes and I just go
I know you feel so relieved yeah but
it's like I don't know I don't feel like
it'll make a difference
well your only option after this is
veneers you can't go back now you need
veneers yeah which would I mean don't
get them super crazy
[__] out here looking crazy
these [__] artists out here got
these [__] teeth
these fools got these [__] surfboards
and it's like oh I see what you did
there
the most unnatural looking [__] horse
smile in the world yeah Mama go with the
person who put my perms in Bollywood
he'd do he did Javonte Davis teeth he do
all the he definitely well he did finish
two times he he did sometimes Got Some
Teeth yeah who doesn't have teeth right
now everybody's got veneers you know
what sucks is we have like a whole
entire generation of hip-hop artists
who have little weird fangs underneath
their fake teeth
yeah
yeah see my my boots are nasty did you
see uh shout out to Texas B King he
actually posted the picture yeah with no
teeth oh my God he appreciated him
showing everybody like this is what this
[__] yeah yeah and that was just with
veneers he never had a group right he
had veneers yeah they I guess he just
got all his [__] actually pulled out and
got like implants yeah and then plants
is the wave but they're painful as [__]
takes a while bro
because he seen he just he just lost a
tooth had to go get a redone he was
eating something in the tooth by the way
Texas Legend yeah for sure for sure him
little Ronnie mother F yeah oh yeah I'd
like to attribute all of the Cucumber
action of like 2018 and 2017. all those
things definitely went there oh my God I
remember seeing like trouble in boozy
did you remember seeing that IG live
pool party yes I was like what the [__]
you ever went to a party like that no I
would I wouldn't want to go what I'm
married oh yeah
my wife would not approve yeah now
somebody who looked like me and had
similar interests as me that was not
married
I cannot confirm nor just confirm that
they would enjoy such events
but me would not enjoy it I wouldn't
even first of all if I win I'd hate it
great man I had a terrible time right
yeah smoothie
it's kind of crazy uh all right man
we'll look the tour is going crazy so
congratulations on the tour appreciate
you it's uh how am I you guys are almost
done yeah we went over past halfway
through it but then right after this
tour we on Kevin Gates tour so Wow have
you met Kevin yet another person though
you guys are gonna have a fun time he's
a very good guy he's also intense
but he's like a hugger you know what I'm
saying like if he [__] with you you're
gonna you guys are gonna hug if you
don't [__] with you I don't know yeah
hey you wouldn't be on but he's a great
dude hit me you might end up Muslim at
the end of the tour though
yeah man I feel like all the rappers are
kicking with Kevin Gates they're Muslim
right after like shout out to [__]
NBA young boys Muslim money back yo got
a nice little movement going on what's
Happening you hung out with Kevin Gates
yeah
hey shout out to my Muslim brothers and
sisters out there you you hey man you're
gonna be praying you're gonna be praying
with Kevin Gates on that tour
yeah I gotta do a record together yeah
for sure that'd be crazy yeah but no we
need to work on Rod wave and big X the
plug doing a song together man we don't
even got to do that I just we just need
to be friends right you need me as a
friend have a good time yeah yeah he's
almost like two bowling balls just
rolling just having the time of their
life I'm glad you said that because I
had to if I knew it was coming I knew it
was coming
all right so uh you and yabo are putting
out a project together and then you and
him
I was probably gonna come first okay or
it's not even just me and his it's like
a like I said this is something
entertainment so I'm looking I'm looking
to sign maybe like two more artists go
before we put the project fit nice
so do we gonna do that then I'm gonna do
the yeah bro then I mean that pool in
Dallas are you trying to put Dallas on
or is it just if somebody could be from
where just I just I just want talent I
want people that's actually hard and
it's actually doing it for the right
reasons you know what I'm saying like
I'm I'm big on loyalty and like just
standing on something in general so
that's what I look for I don't you can
be the hardest rapper in the world but
if you're a if you're a hoe
ain't that the truth
I'm just glad you came through man I
appreciate you for having me pickaxe the
plug of course we're gonna have him
freestyle so you're gonna be able to see
that if you were missing any packages
you know they don't know what happened
one of us allegedly got it allegedly man
[__] FedEx
hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the bootleg cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hardean don't
forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they're gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at hardine in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardeen go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine